for more we can speak now to former
british professional tennis player
annabelle croft annabelle isn't she
great i mean it's so wonderful listening
to her not only is she this phenomenal
athlete but she's also so eloquent at
such a young age
yeah she really is she's a breath of
fresh air isn't she and she's just burst
onto the scene we saw her at wimbledon
obviously and the trauma of uh you know
what happened there where she had the
breathing difficulties out on court one
but my goodness she's come straight back
out onto the tour and taken her game to
a new level and then this fairytale run
through the u.s open i mean it's just
extraordinary as you said in in your
clip there unprecedented i mean no
qualifier has ever won 10 matches back
to back without dropping a set and as
you say it's the manner in which she's
done it all she's done it with so much
joy with poise with composure so at ease
with everything she was born to be a
champion it feels and i feel as if we're
seeing the very beginning of what's
going to be an amazing amazing career in
front of her it's interesting you use
the word joy actually annabelle because
that's a word i've heard so much over
the last 24 hours her her her play is
joyful isn't it when she's actually on
the court you can see she's enjoying it
but she's also joyful in that interview
she's lapping it up and i guess that
does bode well for the future
it really does i mean it's a very
unusual combination because tennis is a
very gladiatorial sport so you're
normally pitting yourself against your
opponent it's a bit like as i've always
said having an argument with the person
down the other end and who's going to
come out on top so there's a lot of
antagonism between the two opponents
usually and you know it can be quite
spicy but you know you need to put your
psychology up against somebody else
but she seems to do it effortlessly and
with positivity and as she said herself
negativity was never allowed as a child
you know her parents really brought her
up to always be positive and not get
down on herself not to have any negative
thoughts out there and she you know she
really has so much self-confidence and
so much belief her techniques are so
secure there's no weaknesses there so
she can really go out into these arenas
and back herself and really put her best
tennis out there but i think it's such
an interesting combination that she
plays with this serenity you know on her
face a little bit like if the older
viewers uh remember yvonne gulligan
cooley who always had this beautiful
kind of
expression on her face while she was
playing with a lot of joy and smiles and
what have you no sort of antagonism or
anger out there but just to produce your
best tennis and play with freedom and a
joyful spirit and i think it's probably
just what the what the doctor ordered in
the world right now i think you're
absolutely right and we're looking at a
picture now a fantastic picture that
she's posted recently on her instagram
feed of her uh in the center of new york
in front of a billboard with her on it
and you can see that big grin on her
face her instagram followers have gone
through the roof she's up to something
like 1.8 million now and it just goes to
show doesn't it how marketable she's
going to be
oh absolutely i mean she just ticks
every single box doesn't she and on top
of everything i've said in terms of her
tennis it's also her communication
skills because she seems very uh natural
in front of the camera she talks from
the heart you know there's no rehearsed
answers you feel like you're really
hearing from emma herself and um you
know she seems to be so intelligent and
articulate you know we know that she did
so well in her a levels with a maths uh
i think an a star in a in maths and
economics she seems very grounded but
also a really special communicator and
that's something you can't really teach
in anybody um you know i think roger
federer was a great communicator a
little bit of a messiah actually had
such a following i've always said he's
like a religion out there but um she
seems to have that little extra
something which is going to well i i
think she's going to be a great
communicator and the fans are going to
love her
so passionate about the women's game and
you must love the fact that we're all
talking about the women's game at the
moment more than the men's game when it
comes to the us open
well you know i think these things are
in cycles aren't they and there's been
certain periods and eras in time in the
tennis world where it felt like the
men's game was a little bit stronger
than the women's in terms of its appeal
and then it swung a little bit back the
other way and then suddenly we had roger
federer and novak djokovic and rafael
nadal coming onto the scene and suddenly
there was a big attention on that but of
course we had the williams sisters we've
had sharapova we've had hingis clysters
uh you know all sorts of great great
names in tennis but certainly i think
what emma has done in the last couple of
weeks is just bring women's tennis right
back up onto the front pages and in many
ways she knocked off the front pages uh
and the sports page is what novak
djokovic was trying to achieve because
he was trying to take a piece of history
in the men's game and that got a little
bit sidelined by what emma was doing so
you know i think as i said before i
think it's just what we need i think um
it's made it really exciting to look
forward to women's tennis in the future
and i think she will never ever be
playing on the back courts or the
outside courts ever again i think it's
center court all the way yeah it's
wonderful stuff isn't it and just
finally before we let you go um what
advice would you give to her because
she's really at the store incredibly at
the start of her glittering career now
and she is only
18 years old so what advice would you
give her at this stage
oh you know i would i hate to give my
advice because i think she's clearly
doing it all right herself at the moment
i think she's got all the answers and
seems to be so well grounded and has the
right attitude to be able to cope with
it but i know that um i think i saw an
interview the other day where virginia
wade obviously was in new york and she
was um
the last person to win as a brit in the
u.s open and she said that
to emma not to read too much of the
headlines and not to sort of take too
much notice of all of that stuff because
it can get a little overwhelming but
something just tells me that she's going
to be able to cope with everything with
flying colors and i think she's also
said herself that she's just taking it
one step at a time everything is pretty
crazy obviously for her agent and
managers and coaches and everything
there's going to be a huge balance to
strike between the focus that she
clearly has on trying to be the best
tennis player that she can possibly be
and then sifting through all of these
thousands and thousands of requests that
are going to come her way and um it was
something that sharapova had to cope
with a lot because when you're as
photogenic as as emma is you know
there's going to be huge demands for
pictures and photo sessions and fashion
pieces and what have you which will be
fun and she's got to enjoy a little part
of that but it's just getting that
balance right isn't it yeah interesting
i'm sure she'll i'm sure she'll make the
right choices yeah she's been saying
that she's not been checking her phone
very much and that's probably quite
sensible isn't it not going through
those huge number of requests and
messages annabelle great to speak to you
thank you so much good to talk to you
thank you